cada minuto crece un poco más la
atención aquí en Guatemala lo último de
los acontecimientos el hígado a las
elecciones presidenciales Es que la
corte de constitucionalidad acaba de
otorgar un Amparo provisional a favor
del movimiento semilla el por lo que el
tribunal supremo electoral puede podría
proseguir con el proceso electoral Y eso
recordamos pese a la solicitud el
miércoles del Ministerio Público de
suspender de eliminar al partido
político movimiento semilla en ese
sentido el registro de ciudadanos
también anunció que no suspenderá la
personalidad jurídica del movimiento
semilla al contrario
anunció que accionó legalmente contra
ese juzgado que ordenó la suspensión del
movimiento semilla según esa instancia
el juzgado está vulnerando con esa
resolución a la ley electoral y de
políticos que menciona que ningún
partido puede ser suspendido después de
un llamado a elecciones también
agregó que el juzgado está excediéndose
en su autoridad sobre la de los
magistrados del tribunal supremo
electoral a quienes la ley encomienda De
manera exclusiva el control de los
eventos electorales cabe recordar que
esta mañana el mismo ministerio publicó
allá no eh las oficinas del registro de
ciudadanos y un hallamiento que según
testigos ocurrió con Fiscales tapándose
el rostro con pasamontañas